[Music]
well this is unexpected
boring you're the quarry you jerk head
in pain here at Tokyo Game Show 2017 and
we're gonna be surprises to come out of
the Sony conference this year was learn
of the enders yeah in VR I was tipped
off ahead of time by Konami that they
had some VR in the works yeah it was
tied to an existing franchise and of
course you think that'll you survive I
guess or maybe Pez but of all things
done in the Ender's so it's being you
know more or less remastered I think
ported to PlayStation for I don't know
how much extra work they're putting into
it so that games gonna be in HD but you
can also play large sections of it in VR
and we did that I was really excited at
first after playing it I'm a little
concerned now great great okay so
granted when you play a demo on a show
floor yeah dude it's hard it's hard I
mean you have to learn the controls on
the fly you only have ten minutes to
play and so it's very difficult to
really get a hang of things when you add
in the fact that VR is involved and it's
a complex game well you know relatively
complex for VR like zone of the enders
things get even trickier the problem was
the buttons that I was using didn't seem
to have consider where they weren't
consistent they weren't actually
triggering the things they were supposed
to and a lot of this is because the game
is contextual where is if your mech is
like touching the ground they'll do one
binding or if it's floating it'll do
another but in VR and first-person it's
very difficult to get the same sense of
you know where your mech is compared to
playing it in third person yeah and one
of the revelations that kind of
surprised me is that Konami is not
actually handling most of this game oh
really
it is sai games right what if Saiga is
done later granblue fantasy which is a
mobile hit and sai games is working on a
few other projects they're essentially
trying to work their way into the
console space I'm worried this might be
too ambitious of a project yeah for
someone who is kind of cutting their
teeth into the console market especially
with VR being obviously yeah yeah yeah
as someone who has you know plays it on
the Ender's like when it came out was
really happy to have the remaster on ps3
somebody enters - is a fantastic game
I'm really looking forward to that
coming to PlayStation 4 I'm very
reticent to say that I'm excited for the
VR version from your perspective what
did it look like because you were
watching me from the sidelines
look for my perspective look like you
were doing really well so you would do
it assaulting a ship obviously in the
air and you were just like taking out a
bunch of the turrets and stuff it looks
like you were doing what you were
supposed to be doing but it didn't feel
like that no not at all
because there were there were plenty of
instances where I would be attacking an
enemy and they would have a shield and I
would you know sell the PR person
you're telling me I have to beat this I
don't know how to do it like no just
keep trying
I would seemingly just sort of like move
my position and come back it didn't feel
like anything was different but the
results were different okay look I think
this game is really early in development
absolutely yeah I think it's got a long
ways to go
maybe it'll turn itself around I'm am
wary of it was Bernard to be a bit
lively godless it'll be nice to plays
there's gonna be in dues
second runner that can run out yeah with
the peaceful sort of green mossy the
considered finish yes I'm not worried
about the first game any of yo that
that's all hat that's sort of there's no
wash down no but I've got a nervous yes
so stay tuned for a second runner Anubis
Mars all those things are kind of zone
of the enders - and stay tuned to
GameSpot for more footage and cover
Kentucky oh and then whatever you want
Tokyo Game Show 2017
I know it's bingo